team sanity let's go i'm so glad that
it's probably chock full of random
events that you can explore and
experience all at once
every time you play zombies you're being
optimistic about this mark
thank you dorothy martin good old lovely
name
is this place supposed to be abandoned
or different sean
yeah did we just oh yeah look at me i'm
a new character model as well
wow we'll check out the prison you guys
check out the car park
all right if we point to something i
keep it in my head it's part of the game
okay cool if we find the ghost 100
points for us hell yeah
hell yeah can we sabotage find evidence
yeah yeah if we convince them that they
found a ghost but it's actually us
okay cool 300 points for nice okay
great awesome everybody every piece of
evidence like
50 points cool 50 to 75 it's a range it
depends although i'll let you know when
it happens
if they die and we don't we
automatically win regardless of point
i'm 100 into this i'll go find a knife
we got to get them killed
yeah so i'll get a knife and then we
could just kill them off film around the
bat
yeah exactly well you know maybe i can
make it a little more fun you know stalk
them make it be
they think i'm the ghost and then i'm
like well i'm not the ghost and i
stabbed it hey prisoner what are you in
for
what what nightmare person orders a
single serving donut that's in its own
box
that doesn't make any sense
who gets one donut on the all right
i'm sorry i interrupted that great pun
oh is someone up here
hello oh god jeez hey
hi oh here's the warden's office
oh wow oh it is like heist
oh i don't want to be free
why does everyone have handcuffs
uh oh guys are you getting flickers
oh oh go spotted go spotted i'm in
trouble
i'm in big trouble big trouble big
trouble here big trouble big trouble
here
big trouble big trouble big trouble
[Music]
i feel like he was either still upstairs
or he was to the cells to the right as
you walk in
push my nipples up through the bars and
you can touch them you need human
contact it's been a while
did something just get thrown at me dude
are you throwing
it was my sexuality these son of a
[ __ ]
these sons are [ __ ] these lazy sons
of [ __ ]
off here touching each other's nipples
out
in this cell block instead of being with
me you save me from the ghost
oh three celsius five celsius this is
the room
mark's right here well not anymore
oh [ __ ] not good
well you know if they all die it's
because they abandoned
[Laughter]
that bob hey how are you doing
you all right there does this mean we
lost about us killing them first
hey why did you kill bobby hey it's good
man it's good
uh just been hanging around making
now that you're dead too you see by
plight but it's okay
why are you looking at my course i'm up
here yeah well you know
i'm just wondering if i can slip into it
you know try it out for size
my face is up here okay yeah well
your body's down here and your body's
what i really care about
hopefully they die and then uh that
means no one wins and we don't lose so
it's kind of like points getting down
hey dumbass hey dumbass
come this way ghost is really whack
and my name it'd be jack if you come in
my zone and you spew in hey
pay attention there's writing in the
book there's writing in the book there's
writing in the book there's writing in
the book look at the book
look at the book look at the book look
at the book look at the book look at the
book
look at the book look at the book
oh there we go oh my god
is he not going to give us credit is he
not going to give credit to us
he's just said wade that like he found
it you think that's what's going to
happen
if you do die all your friends just take
take credit for your accomplishments to
the ends of their days
well great job everybody yeah great job
especially
the one who great yeah
both bob and i were like desperately
trying to guide you to the book
and we're throwing objects like leading
a trail up there and then when you get
there you
say to wade i found the book
didn't mention us at all we couldn't
believe it
look i you
on my thing
are these fences shaking for anyone else
you're the
one no i hear
you do you do the good drugs before we
came out here man
what are the bad news i don't think yes
i do hear it every now and then
well those are both believable which one
is it
matt lobos do you prefer
yukio kirkpak openings or pokemon
matt lobos have you ever bent over in
front of a mirror and looked how strange
your butthole looks
i don't think matt lobos wants to party
there's a lot of soap in these showers
there really is yeah oh my god
what the [ __ ] uh
nothing amazing this door just opened
real fast
it looks like you could run it uh but
guys can you confirm you're hearing
singing oh my god oh my god
oh roger uh roger dodger in my face
ghost
singing i found it matt lobos is a great
singer
and has a great set of tits so through
this doorway
uh i heard a humming and little to my
surprise i looked
out and a shadow ghost was standing
there silhouetted against the backdrop
of the
concrete walls ghost explain
explain the single serve donuts that's
not good
that's not what you want where'd this
thing spawn at
uh good question kind of oh that's
that's a bad sign
bumpity somebody thumb thumb thumping
your thumb thump i'm running away
why is it coming for me okay yeah uh
you're good i think okay good wait do
take one for the team
i hear hearing yeah it's grudging up a
storm over there that earth's like doing
mouthwash we did find a toothbrush and
toothpaste
uh well they have good height dude
i don't see it oh i see it okay we're
good
wait are you dead oh my god no i
expertly dodged it around some tables
and it turned around and left you know
what i'm gonna go get the camera and set
it up over here
oh well this is difficult oh this is
aggressive
you saw him first in this room right no
i saw the ghost
first in was it this one
yeah right in here it was right in here
the first time i saw it it was standing
right there against that wall
i put a motion sensor on the outside of
the room i'm just gonna
hope it gets it how do i place things
again
[Music]
yeah thumps are real it comes from over
here it comes from over here
oh oh i see it out bye i see no no
you're not dead
no oh yeah it's oh it's coming oh it's
coming
oh matt lobos is coming oh hey friend oh
don't get stuck in the door
okay yeah no no door stuck keep coming
all right yeah so we are faster than it
yeah
well i mean we are at top speed
sprinting hot and heavy down the
corridors here
what the hell was that what was what was
that
huh maybe it's maybe the ghost doesn't
exist after all maybe it's all a lie
i'm thinking that by process of
elimination we could probably deduce
what it is based on what it's not doing
right you know what
yeah maybe we just haven't been thorough
enough ooh the motion detector being
bombed did we get that
we did oh hey
okay so it's in that hallway yeah well i
think
that look i found it in that room if we
okay if i deduce down if it's if it
absorbs
yeah ghost storms if it was freezing
temperature ghost orbs and maybe ghost
riding
then it would be a yury oh god was that
was that shawn's
dead body twitching in the wall that you
just flipped by
oh sean is dead oh yeah that one you
keep flipping by the camera that he's on
there he is
there he is oh you what are you doing i
didn't see it i didn't see it i bet it's
a yuray
i'm gonna bet money so i'm gonna take in
this notebook and i'm gonna
i bet that's gonna be the thing i'm
gonna go get him get him
oh i'm going in alone okay that's fine
all right i'm gonna put this in the room
that it's outside of
i think it's gonna work what do i do to
make it work
what do i what do i do to make the thing
oh right here my breath was fogging in
this room oh it's in the hallway
i'm smooching oh oh i might be dead
i'm dead you're dead oh
please don't write in the book write in
the book write in the book write your
memoir in the book
oh i saw it oh my god oh you did it you
did it
did we get did it get smooched it might
have it must be in this hallway because
i don't know i think we're in it right
now
oh god oh it's doing stuff it's just
hunted haunted me from over here i put
the book down and i put the camera
pointing towards the book so that you
know we could see it
well i might die are you there oh hey
oh you're looking good
how are you no emf the ghost writing's
down but i don't see anything in it
this one doesn't want to be found i'm
coming outside before i die a horrible
death look i think this ghost is a
fickle [ __ ] you guys got the book right
oh yeah the book is on the floor in this
room now so
okay i'll bring are you second floor got
it
thank you sean it's the first floor it's
the little like guard room
on the oh [ __ ] yeah that spawns in here
well don't give up just yet where are
you guys we just
outran the ghost by about six inches to
survive
oh wow so where was this room
uh it's out there go back out go left
and then stay on the left side of the uh
the like divided hallway the room that
the book is in on the floor it's like a
little
room okay
no i don't know who had that i have it
i have it oh
god jesus christmas
oh yeah emf just lit up like a
firecracker we got four
all right no not five let me try the uh
are you here
nothing on spirit box put the emf on the
ground is that work
i can't see a goddamn drop it
oh well oh look guys i tried all right
do the spirit box i'll watch this
do you want to kill us
eat my ass oh [ __ ] get out of here
okay getting out oh that sounds bad
oh that sounds very bad no it's i'm
behind you so i got a bad feeling about
that
you have f5 confirmed for sure mf5
confirmed
so it was not a uray unless we like to
take the stairs
no no no i got a good feeling about this
yeah me too i'm sure wade's fine yeah
he's fine
you died sadly to a phantom wait let's
go
good job boys you found maria thanks how
long were you trying to tell me to go in
that room by throwing things
on it honestly not that long she just
spawned in there and i saw it and i went
in and then you came in
right after that that was a very angry
phantom i'm also not the room leader so
i can't set us up a job oh it's me
all right you guys won uh amateur
high school yeah what did you just say
to me
wait i actually do have professional
prison for some reason i don't know why
have a professional road house if you
guys want that roadhouse either one
though i will say
the houses seemingly there's like a bug
where those are a lot rarer than prison
today
that's right let's mix it up let's mix
it up
houses shouldn't i'm gonna set up video
cameras in the house just so we can i
can get bird's eye view of everything we
need thermo
we need below 10 celsius in a room and
we need to walk through salt i want salt
there's not salt i'm this all boy
call me okay all right okay
all right boys i want to clean run in
here
what's that oh okay wash your ankles i
don't have
i forgot i don't have a
not flashlight but three celsius i mean
that sounds promising
i'm coming all right i'm gonna place my
last camera down
my god i'm out of here guys see you
around hey have fun down there i'm gonna
go with the truck and watch
all right i'm looking at my
professionally set up camera oh and i do
not see anything to see a couple of
bumbos flailing their flashlights around
bumbos bumble's coming
bombos oh my god bumbo's you're in
trouble
bombos come in mark is that you spamming
the radio like a madman
uh it wasn't me all the time no it was
okay but we do not have ghost orbs but
the
ghost is a lovely lady
what was the other thing we needed
fingerprint finger
finger writing fingerprints ghost ready
or ghost doors
okay no ghostwriting
oh my god hi hello jesus mark how's it
going
look i don't know what they updated i
see foot i hear footprints and then i
just get scared
you go in there you check for
fingerprints you do that i gotta watch
your camera somewhere else no i do not
why would i do that it's professionally
placed
uh wade oh god yeah well he's dead
oh did i get the salt one hell yeah i
got the salt oh hell yeah you got the
salt one
dude oh yeah there he is he's dying he's
dying he's dying and he's dead oh no
sean's walking over to watch him die
that's so
sad oh that was really neat
yeah wow all right weight is dead
yeah we watched well we yeah
yeah we saw him we saw the whole thing
so does he did he like lose all of his
stuff
because that'd be hilarious yeah
everything he brought which is almost
everything this entire round he just
lost
that's really funny that is actually
really funny
it's not that funny
i hear him from the beyond you know i
can still hear his voice
oh hey guys i'm gonna need you to hurry
up and get this
uh last piece of evidence we're really
kind of running behind schedule here
okay well did you loot his corpse too uh
no not do that get well unless he had
the uh
infrared then get that and then go look
for fingerprints because i think that's
what we need
okay i don't know where the infrared is
i don't think he had that
all right well he walked out of the
truck with it so it's somewhere in the
house good luck
are you you okay
whatever uv infrared they're the same
thing
okay well that's a problem um
oh wait check the book did i see
something in the book
oh yeah there it is okay patricia moore
patricia moore patricia moore patricia
moore patricia moore patricia moore
patricia moore hey
[Applause]
you wanted me dead no what
crazy thoughts that's weird
it's a demon i only see one demon here
okay all right is it in the truck yes
okay well you know
good we'll take it with us it's got
shame written all over its face
uv writing hey you know that's okay we
all have shame in some
it's all good well i hope everybody hey
demon you know man i made some good
money may have stopped paying attention
for a while there
so uh they went 1500 worth of materials
well maybe you shouldn't have died also
uh could have gotten into heaven
but there was like a two dollar entrance
fee and someone looted my corpse
so couldn't afford the two dollar
entrance fee hey wait can you uh can you
add some stuff
items can you add the items yeah i'm
working on rebuying them all right now
okay can you hurry up come on wade
i actually spent 1600 rebuying
everything that's oh my god how much are
you going to go on about how much things
cost
like such a martyr calm down i uh i
threw like a hundred bucks worth of gear
on there so uh
i thought i'm down mr level 357 here we
go ready everybody yes
three two one we all have good energy
going into this one right
you said good energy we said we're
starting with good energy man no
no bad energy going around no bad energy
we are hunting the ghosts of robert
williams
alone that's a fake name i have thermo
and books
i have got my eye on you guys so don't
worry about a thing
scanning for ghost orbs in the various
halls not seeing nothing
you can also watch my pov mark i brought
my head mounted camera
that's good good job
just for sandy's sake who's going into
the room of the chief security officer
just now
me okay so that's wade be aware uh
whoever's in cell block b
a door just opened above you on the
floor above you
and now it's closed not seeing ghost
orbs on your pov
fingerprints oh fingerprints
fingerprints on the
wardens door on the inside that sounds
like a winner
for some reason uh the camera you're
carrying has
exited the map and it is falling into
infinity in my pov
oh no i need to get another one i guess
no no i don't know
it's spinning around as it's falling oh
it's back
how's that camera angle on the
stationary uh
looking pretty good no ghost orbs to be
found just yet
wait what you took my money i'm not dead
this time
here three degrees celsius
six no freezing keep an eye on that emf
i got in there right as it
disappeared but i think it was up to a
five uh
yeah i'm not so sure about that room i
haven't seen a thing happening in there
hello oh my god you got it you guys got
to stop sneaking up on the truck
can i help you sir
i got to be blasting into the radio no
i'm eye in the sky
it says love or die uh ghost did you
know that you can dip your doritos in
dip
as well you don't just have to eat them
on their own emf five confirmed my dude
emf that's the worst case scenario
because you can't outrun a revenant
try all right we also did get the
crucifix thing so uh you're
everything's checked off you're good to
go
it's really weird how there's still
three head mounted cameras on the bus
that's so strange
hey good job guys i'm not in the best
mood for pictures right now
that was clean guys that was clean work
clean line work at me
yeah it sure was okay good well done
gang
so do you guys think that we should pay
america full weight for today
or hey i was high in the sky daddy in
the truck
next time big daddy in the truck mark
next time
you're on the ground because someone
else gets to be uh
why why though i did such a good job
i and he's eating he got lunch before
the rest of us
hey who's gonna get cold chicken fill it
no if you want something i don't have it
amy is coming up to
near san francisco tomorrow you need
anything from down here she can get it
to you intermediate prison
or professional prison professional
prison
professional i got a good feeling about
this one gang
but it looks like whoever was here
elizabeth davis if i could request you
please remember your head mounted
cameras i would be much obliged
look at the forehead it doesn't just say
dumb anymore the dominant is covered
over by a camera mark get your head
camera i can't bring harder
i have a emf let's split up gang i
haven't put the book down but i did see
some graffiti on a wall it says
sean hart foot china
yeah i wrote that with a smash stick
when it came in
anyone else hear that noise
kind of like uh no
no sean's writing i don't know what that
means about the material he used to
write it
big daddy in the trucker are you are you
watching over us
all right bob's dead oh cold wait
something just was cold i got cold when
he said
again too oh i'm i'm hearing something
over here oh is this where dirty water
is
the dirty water i think dirty water's in
here
is there any water
dirty water oh it's freezing
temperatures
where are you yeah let's go
kill waves
what do you want the hell is that noise
are you making crinkles in real life
no
get a picture oh she's in her jammies
[Applause]
[Music]
we're so very good at ghosts i'm proud
of you guys
i got farmhouse professional that's what
i got grabbed oh my god the farmhouse i
have not seen that in twenty
bucks yes all right we just need ghost
event
hunting no do with crucifix and ghost
pick
elizabeth robinson alone
done elizabeth taylor i'm out this [ __ ]
let's go
good luck out there good luck out there
i'll keep the popsicles cool for you see
you around all right i'll bring in some
cameras
yeah it's dark it's dark in here
no one turned on any lights trying to
put some cameras down here
oh dark vision all right uh i didn't put
any cameras up in that back room so
uh yep oh
actually actually ghost orb
so ghost writing spirit box
and emf it needs to be alone fyi
and also you're gonna did anyone grab a
[Applause]
crucifix
i put a crucifix in there so let me know
if that one gets checked off mark oh
spirit
coming out eliza you got the crucifix
crucifix has been crossed off your life
was
killings saved on oh my god you're so
loud we got any killings going on
that's worse i'll go ahead and volunteer
and i'll be bait and i'll just like let
it kill me and he can get a good pick of
it strangling me
oh okay i'm running i'm running
okay let's go let's go home back it up
boys
oh no no no
oh no guys guys
i'm trapped they were right behind me
they got trapped guys
don't let it touch you stand in your
corners
you're all right okay
i can't see them through the window
they're upstairs they're cowering in
fear
hey you guys alive yeah those are weird
something all right yeah that was
unfortunate timing for you guys
what you doing what are you guys doing
in the corner
what is happening what is going on
oh my god what is any of that what's
happening
you uh you're all naruto
into the corner i don't like it
i don't like any of it we're just
standing in the corner yeah sure you are
okay good yep
oh boy
let's go yeah okay
anyway so bone broth yeah it's pretty
good for you collagen actually is the
most abundant protein in the body
uh your body can't as it ages your body
can't produce enough of it
you know as time goes on so you got to
supplement it with your diet apparently
31 not 60. so like bone broth it's it's
really good
you can actually add some things to it
you can make regular soup you can
actually use bone broth
as any liquid any recipe that needs
water
which is a lot of recipes you could just
use bone broth
really nice consistency and extracting
in there
actually i think that would be delicious
to be perfectly honest i bet if you did
it with chicken breasts
right it would be like it would be like
like rice right yeah yeah yeah
definitely hello
ding-dong hello
uh oh is that freezing no that's smudge
that's smudged go you
tricked me good you good bro
nice bro nice leave or die
i could do it look sean you got your
coffee which i drank this morning very
good
top of the morning coffee but uh i could
do markiplier's
thick bone broth yeah there's a bustling
corner of the market for that get out of
here okay bye
my room i'm temperature
thanks man bro have you heard about bone
broth though
oh [ __ ] dude wait i'm gonna come back to
the truck i'll tell you all about it
where is it where'd he go where'd he go
where'd he go where'd he go where'd he
go wade
wait where's that hiding oh he went
through the other door didn't he oh he
probably did
i put some cameras in the room bronies
the bronies brony bro oh we need a photo
of the ghost and dirty water right
i'm done with dirty water dirty water
like bone water
you think that the group will get
together and talk about bone broth call
themselves
the bone broth
yeah man are you a bone brother yeah but
bone broth
slash bone broth god that's gonna be
there's going to be a subreddit so so
soon but honestly it can kill you
it's going to be full of that type of
talk as well talk about dude my elbow
was creaking and then i got the collagen
bro
my elbow was so good afterwards
hey where did you close the door wait
wait come on wait there's some of that
bone broth right you know what i mean
oh you trying to get the ghost in here
you want to be alone
use your words wait wait
wait wait wait what's the funniest thing
wait right now
not really a bone broth he probably
wants to be alone
whoa the book just got knocked off of
the desk
i didn't know that could happen gosh i
might be dead soon literally
i'm so proud right now yeah the book
just literally fell on the floor
i've never seen that can we get name
confirmation
oh [ __ ] wait okay i'm ready where is it
okay i'm ready for it i'm ready for it
you see it oh it's out here
it's in the hallway it's out here by me
okay
i think i got it did i get it
margaret moore one of you died
you got a photo of the ghost we got it
okay
yeah yeah
anyway wait bone broth i've found that
kettle and fire seems to have the
highest quality but it's very
expensive now swanson which is owned by
campbell's they make a
sip and bone broth but it's in these
like non-eco-friendly containers like
it's just
10 ounces of broth for like this hunk
[Applause]
well at least i got a good picture
hey what guys what are you talking about
sure
thank you i got the picture yeah we got
the photo of the ghost
i'm bus man okay your bus man okay
george miller and alone
i'm going i'm gonna go i'll go i'll
guess i'll get the salt okay okay okay
boss
don't forget your lunches okay thanks
mom guys
wait up guys wait wait
up where are you going
all right wait i'm with you buddy jenny
goes all right
hey i saw something uh
yep oh those must have slammed that
doorbell behind us that's weird no i
didn't notice
check one do you got a bone in here does
it have a photo camera
bone music
oh that sounds promising where are you
at 54 degrees
it's pretty spicy
over here by the door
are your lights on is that is
so bright in that room what the hell is
going on well we have no spirit box no
emf and no bulk either what the [ __ ] is
happening
well that's a boring ghost gonna grab
some gear and come show you idiot
hey i brought the salt in here hey hey
who
who the hell took my salt job
who the hell did that who the hell did
that who the hell did that
look i'm putting the salt down on the
ground
and that was me wade
well that implies it's me and that would
just be an implication to make
oh we got a hand we got hands
right there that would make sense
because the door opened on its own
box while we got neither
doing anything i'll do better
what's your name
why are you here
oh spirit box it wants to kill
that's good right that's pretty good
all right yeah fingerprints yeah come
here
hello hi come on down hello
hi come look at those hands
this guy made a mess is anybody alive in
their acknowledge
acknowledge oh dear that's a problem
yep i do believe we're in trouble well
you don't know that for
certain i don't see any ghosts
i would guess fairly strongly that we're
in trouble it's just a race
side escape over here it's a wraith
what's the worst thing that
well this ain't so bad pretty easy if
you ask me
i mean that was pretty
gold has to step into this basically
cage in case the ghost shows up
when's that everybody only killed one of
us right yeah
oh oh easy
well you got the door
open yeah wade are you there wait out
here what happened
yep wait yeah even here all day okay all
right uh wade you have uh five seconds
to get in this truck before we roll out
by way i am rich
hello hello i downed all the pills
because i hate you
hey dude oh cool hey there you are
that's not the ones who weren't
responding on the radio yeah where were
you
wait but he was oh come on
i think we would have acknowledged that
yeah
we think we're both blind i
you all suck
[Music]